un maire adjoint de sarcelles privé de
délégation pour propos racistes il
aurait tenu des propos antisémites
devant un parent d'élève alors qu'il
évoqué les difficultés de circulation
près de la synagogue à sarcelles les
jours de fêtes religieuses
benoît deux buts l'air c'est avant un
conseil d'établissement où il
représentait la mairie que guy chrétien
a dérapé
une discussion sur les embarras de
circulation autour de l'école mais très
vite l'adjoint s'emporte et tient des
propos inadmissibles sur la communauté
juive en présence d'un parent d'élève
émotion les parents sarcelles abrite la
plus importante communauté juive d'île
de france
le maire alerté retire toutes ses
délégations à son adjoint est devenu
confronter avec la personne et qui était
la plaignante et que j'ai constaté qu'il
avait effectivement tenu des propos
inadmissibles je lui ai notifié tout de
suite que je lui retirait sa délégation
et ses propos me donne à penser que bon
il a peut-être dépassé un peu sa pensée
mais qu'il y avait quand même quelque
chose on ne dit pas ça on ne peut pas on
ne doit pas le dire dix chrétiens n'a
pas été exclue du conseil municipal le
maire n'a pas le pouvoir mais les
parents estiment avoir obtenu
satisfaction
aujourd'hui les juifs de sarcelles
souhaite retrouver la paix et considère
que l'incident est clos